[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition spéciale sur tv
60,18 bienvenue si vous nous rejoignez
dans cette émission du mercredi 15 avril
pour débuter cette immense nuage de
fumée noire que vous avez peut être
aperçu aujourd'hui ali mer un important
incendie s'est déclaré ce matin vers
11h30 dans la zone portuaire et les
pompiers sont intervenus à l'entreprise
gde spécialisée dans le broyage de
voiture il ne s'agit pas d'un site
seveso et ne stocke pas de produits
chimiques confirme la préfecture des
yvelines
et d'après les premiers éléments le feu
serait parti d'un véhicule rempli
d'essence l'incendié a été circonscrit
aux alentours de 15h à la une toujours
le nombre de victimes du coronavirus qui
continuent de grimper dans les yvelines
d'après les dernières données publiées
hier par santé publique france 2 192
décès ont été recensés dans le
département soit 16 de plus entre lundi
et mardi
mais en 24 heures les hospitalisations
en thelle baissé de 16 cas dans les
yvelines 1054 patients étaient
hospitalisés hier mardi
183 placé en réanimation le nombre de
retour à domicile suite à une
amélioration de l'état de santé
augmentent toujours il s'établit à 814
dans cette crise sanitaire la situation
est très préoccupante dans les ehpad 60%
des établissements d'île de france ont
déclaré avoir au moins un cas de kovy de
19 pour ses sites touchés la rs et la
préfecture de région a annoncé hier le
lancement d'une vaste campagne de
dépistage dans les maisons de retraite
objectif atteindre d'ici la fin de
semaine les cinq mille tests par jour
sur le territoire francilien et des
renforts d'effectifs sont également
prévus pour remplacer les personnels à
malades ou empêchés dans ces ehpad
un millier de personnes a été affectée
depuis le début de la semaine en
première ligne également dans la lutte
contre le coc vide 19 les pharmacies
mobiliser auprès de la population et des
professionnels de santé
c'est notamment le cas de l'officine
situé au centre commercial espace saint
quentin à montigny le bretonneux
elle s'est réorganisée pour répondre au
mieux aux besoins en toute sécurité
le reportage de nicolas landry et de
mathilde de me rassurer et conseillers
la population fournir en matériel
médical les professionnels de santé les
pharmacies sont en première ligne dans
cette crise sanitaire ventes de gels
hydro alcooliques mais interdiction pour
l'instant de commercialiser des masques
au grand public
les dotations sont réservés
aux professionnels de santé
comptabilisés à peu près une bonne
cinquantaine de professionnels de santé
dans un environnement géographique
proche
je vous laisse deviner la complexité de
distribuer 18 masques par personne par
semaine par professionnels de santé
sachant qu'on en reçoit à peu près 150
200 par livraison tous les quinze jours
autre activité 30 à 40 livraisons de
médicaments par jour aux personnes
seules et fragile
une solidarité interprofessionnelle
s'est mise en place avec les acteurs
médicaux du territoire on a créé un
groupe avec ses pharmaciens pour
justement attribué pour donner une
dotation minimum en masques aux
professionnels de santé
cirque tel médecin il raconte telle
pharmacie prendre ces des gymnastes l
infirmière il ira dans telle pharmacie
voilà donc on a pu s'organiser de la
sorte le président de la république l'a
annoncé le port du masque pourrait se
généraliser à partir du 11 mai les
pharmacies se prépare pour répondre à ce
défi
moi je suis prête demain je peux avoir
je peux voir diminue masque en tissu que
je serai prêt à vendre quasiment au prix
coûtant
dans ma pharmacie pour pour répondre aux
besoins de la population donc j'ai
contacté alors j'ai contacté
maire-adjoint en charge de la de la
santé de montigny-le-bretonneux pour lui
dire voilà si ça va passer par vous il
n'y a pas de souci si cela passait par
mois ça peut se faire également les
pharmacies pourrait aussi s'engager dans
le dépistage de masse ici les
pharmaciens sont déjà prêts ils
attendent juste l'autorisation
administrative
c'est l'une des conséquences
malheureuses du confinement les
violences à l'intérieur du foyer ont
augmenté depuis quelques semaines
mathilde demi bons soirs comme ça de la
rédaction de tv 60,18 vous parlez vous
plus particulièrement de la hausse des
violences conjugales avec votre invité
est oui nous sommes avec gaël démarre
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes coordinatrice
du collectif nous tout 78
donc je rappelle c'est un collectif qui
milite contre les violences sexistes et
sexuelles depuis le début du continent
le ministre de l'intérieur a constaté
une hausse des violences conjugales de
30% en france
est ce le même constat dans les yvelines
voyez à priori dans les yvelines ça
suffit
même tendance j'ai pas de chiffres
exacts mais on sait qu'au niveau des
plateformes de chat ou d'appels
il ya une hausse de 20 à 30% des
contacts certaines femmes et enfants
sont du coup contenait avec des
personnes violentes
comment peut-on donner l'alerté agir
durant le confinement alors il ya
plusieurs systèmes qui sont possibles
que c'est pas toujours facile d'appeler
justement pour donner des alertes quand
l'agresseur est présent avec nous donc
il ya des systèmes de chat qui sont
également accessibles la nuit sur
arrêtons les violences point gouv.fr il
est possible aussi de contacter par sms
le 114
il est possible aussi dans les
pharmacies de donner l'alerté
pharmaciens sont au courant de la
procédure et peuvent contacter ensuite
la police et puis dans les yvelines ya
aussi des permanences qui commencent à
être mises en place dans les centres
commerciaux donc notamment il y en a une
à plaisir le mardi après-midi de 13h à
17h à auchan et à mantes la jolie le
jeudi de 13h à 17h il ya aussi également
une ligne d'écouté à destination des
auteurs de violences elle a été activée
le 6 avril
est-ce que vous pensez que ça va
permettre d'éviter les passages à l'acte
ça peut éviter le problème c'est que les
auteurs de violences sont pas forcément
conscients en fait du problème qui
peuvent avoir mais si en effet pour ceux
qui arrivent à prendre conscience de ça
je pense que ça peut les aider de
pouvoir d'avoir cette possibilité là
d'en parler à quelqu'un et est-ce qu'il
ya d'autres dispositifs mis en place par
le gouvernement
le 39 19 à 20 ans quels numéros qui est
communiqué par tous donc est joignable
en appelant donc ça c'est vraiment un
numéro qui va permettre d'orienter
ensuite vers d'autres associations qui
pourront aider
plus précisément et puis pour les
enfants il ya le 119 aussi si jamais
vous entendez des enfants qui crient
qu'ils peuvent êtres en souffrance
n'hésitez pas à contacter le 119 pour
alerter et en cas d'urgence absolue si
vous sentez qu'il ya une mise en danger
c'est de 17 qu'il faut appeler la police
merci d elle démarre d'avoir répondu à
nos questions merci à vous et merci à
vous mal tilde je précise d'ailleurs
dans les mines plusieurs acteurs sont
engagés dans la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes on parlait
de cette association ce collectif nous
tout il ya également le cidff qui est le
centre d'information pour le droit des
femmes et des familles qui a cinquante
antennes sur le territoire alors en ce
moment forcément un tout est remise en
question mais en tout cas le numéro qui
s'affiche vous pouvez le joindre à
montigny le bretonneux
il ya également un centre qui s'appelle
équinoxe qui héberge l'étincelle c'est
un lieu d'accueil de jour des victimes
enfin il ya aussi une autre association
l'association women safe qui prend en
charge ces femmes victimes de violence
ainsi que leurs enfants
après les annonces des manuels macro
lundi il ne pouvait plus se tenir en
l'état prévue initialement du 27 juin au
19 juillet le tour de france 2020 sera
bien reporté c'est une première en
france depuis la seconde guerre mondiale
l union cycliste internationale a
confirmé la tenue de la 107e grande
boucle à partir du 29 août
la 21e et dernière étape de la
compétition s'élancera elle de mantes la
jolie le 20 septembre 122 km direction
les champs elysées à paris écoutez la
réaction du maire de mantes-la-jolie
joint par téléphone moi je considère que
ce report est une très bonne nouvelle
parce que sans la crainte si c'est que
tour n'est pas lui le fait qu'on ait au
moins de septembre un événement
rassembleur comme le tour de france
c'est une excellente nouvelle pour
manque pour les yvelines mais
globalement pour toute la france
ça change pas grand chose parce que le
début du mois de septembre est
traditionnellement un droit qui est
assez chargé avec la rentrée scolaire
est incertain des vêtements et fin
septembre puisque ce sera demain on est
tout à fait en capacité d'organiser les
choses donc on sera en parfaite
situation pour accueillir le tour et je
rends compte tu tout heureux d
engouement au contraire je pense qu'on
aura forcément un petit peu moins de
public mais je crois aussi qu'on aura
vraiment c'est en espérant que cette
épidémie sera derrière nous des
vêtements fédérateur sur lesquels les
gens vont pouvoir se réunir se
rassembler au faire la fête ensemble
et depuis le début du confinement les
cours de sport en ligne et à domicile
envahissent les plateformes vidéo à
voisins le bretonneux la compagnie il
ici dance a décidé d'assurer la
continuité de ces ateliers en visio
conférences des sessions ouvertes à tous
pour apprendre de nouvelles
chorégraphies mathilde et demi la veille
du confinement
la compagnie illicites dance décide
d'enregistrer un flash mob et quelques
vidéos de chorégraphies pour faire
passer le temps à leurs élèves
quelques jours plus tard elle décide de
proposer des ateliers en visioconférence
j'ai commencé au début par par créer des
petites chorégraphies et les envoyer aux
personnes intéressées et finalement très
vite pour le confinement a commencé à
durer
plus il y avait de la demande donc je me
suis dit en effet pourquoi pas ouvrir
des ateliers en live ça s'est beaucoup
développée du coup en ce moment en plus
j'ai vu pas mal sur les réseaux ailleurs
donc je dis parfois pourquoi pas nous
tous les élèves se connecte sur une
application pour rejoindre l'atelier au
programme des échauffements du
renforcement musculaire et
l'apprentissage d'une nouvelle
chorégraphie
je pense que ça fait du bien à tout le
monde de faire un petit peu de sport et
puis puis de s'amuser puisque je pense
que la danse le cercle ça fait faire un
peu de sport mais c'est aussi un moyen
de décompresser de penser à rien d'autre
pendant une heure une heure et demie et
est donc et puis on sent bien que ça
fonctionne que depuis qu'on a lancé et
d'ateliers saffon serait plutôt plutôt
bien pour adeline assurer une continuité
des ateliers était primordial pour le
bien-être de ses élèves pendant le
confinement les visio conférences sont
ouvertes à tout le monde
en plus des adhérents de la compagnie on
peut continuer justement a créé alors
apprendre des choses et ça développe
autre chose des ateliers se déroulent à
partir de 19 heures les lundis pour les
adultes et les mardis pour les
adolescents et à 17 heures les mercredis
pour les enfants pendant une heure et
demie les participants peuvent
transpirer en toute sécurité en cette
période de confinement votre rubrique
hebdomadaire dans les salles devient
dans vos canapés pour vous proposer des
films à voir et directement depuis chez
vous ce soir c'est le versaillais
vincent mirabel professeur de cinéma qui
nous parle de stand by me réalisé par
rob renner est sorti en 1986
quels sont vos coups de coeur qu'elle
filme peut-on regarder pendant cette
période de confinement c stand by me de
rob reiner un film de 1986 j'ai trois
atouts pour lequel j'ai choisi ce film
le premier c'est que c'est une
adaptation réussie d'un roman de stephen
king
alors ici il n'y a aucun élément
horrifique comme dans shining ou dans sa
ni aucun élément surnaturel comme dans
la ligne verte
c'est juste un récit initiatique qui en
fait composé d'un souvenir marquant de
quatre adolescents qui vont partir dans
la forêt et qui vont vivre une aventure
qui va les aider en fait à passer à
l'âge adulte
donc ça fait un moment donné un peu peur
mais c'est surtout formidable et ça
n'est jamais angoissant totalement donc
c'est un film extrêmement juste cette
histoire pleine d'événements c'est une
promenade riche et à la fois touchante
et très profonde
du point de vue de gier et psychologique
d'autre part les acteurs sont tous
excellents et j'en citerai un seul qui
ait river phoenix la river phoenix en
fait c'est le petit frère de joaquin
phoenix vous savez l'interprète de joker
et river phoenix dans ce film il n'a que
16 ans et il est promis à une très
grande carrière parce qu'il est
excellent néanmoins malheureusement sept
ans plus tard il sera victime d'une
overdose et ce sera un deuil pour toute
la famille phoenix tous les personnages
sont bien caractérisée il ya le sage
philosophe il ya le pacifiste
intelligent il y a le balourd qui est un
peu le souffre douleur
et puis l'enfant battu qui est agité
plein plein de colère donc tous ces
jeunes vont constamment fonctionner à
l'écran enfin une dernière chose très
importante c'est qu'il ya une excellente
bo dans ce film et
dont la chanson stand by me la fameuse
chanson tube de ben king a donné en fait
son titre au film n'aura justement c'est
une chanson cam un record absolument
unique dans toute l'histoire de la
musique
elle a été un tube dans les années 50 et
grande cinq ans plus tard elle redevient
un tube numéro un au hit parade pendant
des semaines mais sans aucune
modification de la chanson c'est à dire
c'est l'interprète initial avec les
musiques initial et le rythme initial
ça c'est absolument unique même les
beatles ou michael jackson n'ont jamais
eu ce type de record à 35 ans
d'intervalle la chanson est deux fois
numéro un dans un pays majeur comme les
états unis
et puis ces images fortes avant de se
quitter il ya tout juste un an la
cathédrale notre dame de paris
s'embrasait une scène qui avait
largement émules incendie avait
grandement ravagé l'édifice achevé au
14e siècle sont emblématiques flèche
détruite par le brasier
les causes de cet incendie sont toujours
inconnues pour l'heure rappelez-vous les
pompiers des yvelines avaient été
mobilisés pour faire face à la
catastrophe leurs actions avaient été
précieuse pour sauvegarder le beffroi
nord de notre dame de paris est les
soldats du feu avait été honoré d'une
médaille par le conseil départemental
des yvelines pour leur bravoure
l'occasion pour nous de les féliciter
une nouvelle fois pour cette action pour
leurs engagements actuels aussi dans
cette crise sanitaire bravo à eux et
aussi à tout le personnel engagé en
première ligne de cette lutte contre le
cros navires us
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale merci de votre fidélité restez
chez vous et très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
et